today we have a really special guest
I've known Kevin wheel for many many
years and our wedding I know but we'll
keep that we won't talk about that today
and it is really special to have him
here to share his story since we're
going to be doing an interview today I'm
not going to do a formal introduction
but I'm going to let Kevin tell you a
little snapshot about his story about he
how he got from where he was sitting as
a student seat to here sitting in the
front of the room
sure so well I grew up in Redmond home
of Microsoft and my dad was there for
probably 20 years so I learned to
program when I was young but then got
super into physics and math so I went to
Harvard for undergrad studied physics
and math came out to Stanford where I
thought I was going to be a physics
professor for the rest of my life
like I was studying theoretical physics
all I wanted to do then met my now wife
who was a Mayfield fellow here at
Stanford was part of part of this world
and she kind of opened my eyes to the
whole to everything that is to look in
Valley around all of us I really just
had blinders on had no idea and I kind
of got hooked the idea that you know I
could join a company and and start
creating things and shipping things so I
jumped out started working at a couple
startups as an engineer got the
opportunity to join Twitter started
working on data on analytics back when
Twitter was about 40 people somehow in
the middle of all that ended up moving
to the product side and you know that
the fun parts of working at a small and
class growing company somehow ended up
running the product team after about
seven years and then moved to Instagram
a little over a year ago so it's been a
wild ride
so let's flashback to when you were at
Harvard you were in school there at the
same time as Mark Zuckerberg what did
you think about his decision to leave
school to go start a company yeah I'm
gonna I'm going to embarrass myself this
is this is the part where you realize
you're always smarter than I am I
I was it so I was I'm a year older than
mark so we were at Harvard at the same
time and you know he dropped out after a
couple of years so he started a couple
things at Harvard got in trouble for a
bunch of them then started building
Facebook it took off like wow
fire throughout the campus and he came
out here I think for a summer maybe
after his freshman or sophomore year and
it didn't come back and so I think that
was after his sophomore year I'm a
junior at this point and I'm sitting
here going everyone knows him it he's
kind of infamous on campus I'm sitting
here going he's giving up a Harvard
degree to go work on some company what
an idiot
as I went and continued and got my
degree and now twelve years later I'm
working for him well yes but like the
last thing that you then came here for
your PhD and you left your PhD program
to go into industry how hard was that
decision why don't you talk about that
calculus yeah it was it was a weird
decision actually to be honest because I
was I was so invested in like I was
studying theoretical physics I wanted to
be a physics professor because like what
else do you do in theoretical physics
degree um and and then I met my wife
Elizabeth who was you know very much she
paid her way through college basically
working at startups and it kind of just
opened my eyes to this whole new world
where in physics especially in
theoretical physics you're lucky if you
make a contribution over a lifetime and
it's fascinating and the contributions
are fundamental when they're made and
they advance human knowledge all sorts
of amazing things but then I got this
taste of like Oh or I could go to a
company in between nine and five I could
ship something to millions of people and
I could you know create and I just got
hooked and it was sort of I got I passed
my calls got my master's degree you know
fell okay I had done just enough and
went and and joined the workforce
actually joined a company called Tropos
Networks does anybody remember Tropos
networks nobody in the Wow nobody
alright alright they were doing
municipal Wi-Fi and the interesting
thing was it was founded by a bunch of
PhD physics dropouts so it was about as
smooth of an entry into the workplace as
you could have imagined because I was
working with a bunch of other dropouts
like myself great well then when you
join Twitter
there were only four to 40 people I'd
love to know about your decision to do
that and also how your role
changed as the company grew yeah it's so
my job before Twitter I started working
on this technology called Hadoop people
will probably familiar with the doop a
few more hands than Tropos maybe alright
anyway sort of big data stuff and I'd
seen this it was back in maybe 2007 it
was early and I saw the power for this
technology to change the way that we
asked and answered questions about our
business at this company I was at and I
got the opportunity to go to Twitter and
start the analytics team so at the time
I was the first engineer who wasn't
carrying a pager and you know you
remember Twitter back in 2009 it was up
and down you know we're growing like mad
and the service was constantly having
scaling issues so I was the first person
that got to come in and try to
understand what the data looked like how
were people using Twitter and how could
we understand it to help us build the
product build a better product and yeah
it was 40 people so we were all kind of
figuring out as we went that I'll tell
you one quick story from the from the
back then so I was literally the first
person that was working on the data
everybody else had just been trying to
keep the service afloat as they as they
dealt with massive growth and about two
weeks in I they had a board meeting and
someone said hey Kevin you know you're
you're here you're the analyst guy can
you go figure out how many users we had
this quarter and it meant it meant to
you know I had to go do this sequel
query and it was a particularly
expensive sequel query because I had to
look at the number of distinct user IDs
that had used the service over the last
90 days
and at this time there was no offline
data store like everything the thing
that I had to query was the same thing
that was serving Twitter which by the
way was the same thing that was
basically on fire because we were
growing so fast so I had to come into
work at 3:00 a.m. which was you know as
off-peak as low usage as the time as we
had and do the sequel query and like
watch the rest of the servers across
Twitter and make sure that I wasn't
delaying them too much as I did this
query to get data for this so like
that's that's kind of where Twitter was
and that's where that's where you are as
a company of 40 people trying to grow
really fast
but the exciting thing is we there was
so much opportunity as we grew we went
from 40 to about 4,000 while I was at
Twitter I started doing analytics and
then as we as we kind of build that out
and we got to a place where internally
we knew how Twitter was growing and what
led to success on the service how people
were using the product and what we could
do to make it better for them we started
realize that you know there are a lot of
businesses and other people that are
using Twitter for their livelihood what
if we could use analytics to help them
understand how Twitter was helping them
and how they could use it better so we
started working on that it was just me
and two other two other engineers and
these two guys were far better engineers
than I ever was so as we started
thinking well you know we're building a
product for other people we should
probably go ask them if we're on the
right track one of us had to not be
writing code for a little while to go
ask the potential customers and they
were so much better than I was at what
we were doing it was way better that I
took some time off than they did so I
started doing this and going out and
talking to customers trying to
understand you know if what we were
building made sense for them and that
was kind of the first point where I
transitioned a little bit from being an
engineer and to being more of a product
manager and I was still writing code but
but doing some of that and you know over
time I started doing more of the product
management less of the engineering and
eventually became a product manager that
product turned into our ads product as
we started thinking about building
products for businesses one of the other
things they want to do is they want to
get more reach they want to use the
service to reach potential customers so
that turned into our ad product and you
know I didn't know anything about ads
but I was the guy that was there so so
you know there was an opportunity to to
start working on that and and then I was
fortunate to get to grow with that
product and that team as it grew so that
we took that product from zero dollars
in revenue to about two billion in
revenue over four or five years and
that's I got to grow with the team as it
grew and I sent my last maybe 18 months
overseeing the rest of the product team
as well so not just the ads and business
side but the consumer product and then
things like vine and periscope so just
I could have never in a million years
predicted that I would have taken that
path that I would have gotten the
opportunity to take that path but I
think that's the fun of joining a small
company and and seeing it through a lot
of growth you know opportunities come
your way people took bets on me and I
worked really hard to try and make those
bets good so how did your thinking have
to change as that role change right as
an individual contributor writing code
to then leaving the product team how how
did your thinking about the product and
the companies shift yeah it's a really
good question is I don't think I noticed
this at the time it's more of something
that looking back I have realized but
there's a funny thing when you're an
engineer you know how all the systems
work and then when you're a product
manager you're not really responsible
for knowing how the systems work your
job is to be the voice of the customer
you're supposed to be thinking about
what jobs your product is hired for like
why do people use your product what are
they trying to do what problems does it
solve for them and how can you solve
those problems better but coming from an
engineering world where I knew how the
systems worked it was actually you know
in general it's a strength it's nice to
be it's good to be technical because you
were still building products but the the
challenge I think that I had to overcome
at least was because I knew how the
system's worked I would sort of
short-circuit certain ideas because I
knew they'd be harder than other ideas
and I had to learn to actually like not
use that part of my brain or part of my
history because it's way better you can
think about what problem you're trying
to solve and why independent of whether
it's easy or hard figure that part out
later but you you want to sort of keep
the purity of thinking about the problem
you're trying to solve and not not be
like well I know this one's easier so
maybe we'll try and go in this direction
a little bit because we can do that
faster so I really I had to sort of try
and shut that part of my brain off and
then it kind of happened automatically
because as we grew you know I actually
seemed less and less of the code as time
went on but in the beginning it was I
really had to work at it right so you
could throw it over the fence to the
engineers and say figure out how to make
it work well no it's definitely not that
definitely not that I think it's really
important to be able to work directly
with your team but you just don't want
to be you don't want to be throwing out
certain solutions
just because you know they're hard you
know at the end of the day you do
absolutely work really closely with your
engineering team and may be the perfect
solution is actually not feasible from
an engineering perspective and you find
the sort of 80/20 a value proposition
that you can actually build you just
don't want to be throwing things out at
the beginning you want to do that sort
of towards the end once you figure out
what the right thing is with the team so
you then chose to leave Twitter to go to
Instagram can you talk a little bit
about your thinking about that how did
you evaluate that opportunity and why
did you choose that as opposed to going
to another startup yeah I had an amazing
seven years of Twitter it's a great
company I think it's important for the
world but it was also I worked at a
couple small companies before that but
Twitter was really the only company that
I had ever seen at scale certainly
become my own company I'd ever had any
amount of responsibility at and I kind
of wanted to see how other companies did
things you know some of the things
Twitter did it did really well some of
the things other companies do better and
I didn't have any sense of that so I
really wanted to see other companies but
after seven years my my intention was
actually to take like six months off so
I had I had quietly resigned and was
sort of finishing out my time at Twitter
I when I happened to have dinner with
Kevin Systrom he's a friend of my wife's
and we'd known him for years and she
came over for dinner and at the end of
dinner he was like hey we have this role
open you know would you ever think about
and I was like no I I work at Twitter I
couldn't work it Instagram but then I
was kinda like wait why am i why am i
why would I not learn more Instagram as
an amazing company Facebook is an
incredible company so I I I went it and
just got to know the team a little bit
loved loved everybody I met and also
realized Instagram is it's a company of
about now it's four or five hundred
people at the time I think it was maybe
200 so it was a company of 200 people
with an audience you know the community
of hundreds of millions at the time now
it's over 700 million people to use
Instagram every month and I don't think
there's any place in the world where you
have the the value of being a small
company you can be nimble you can move
quick
all the good things that come with being
a small company and yet you have the
impact and the opportunity to make a
difference at a large a large company
has because we serve an audience of 700
million people so like that combination
to me was just I don't think there's
anywhere else in the world that you can
get that and you know that together with
the people I'd be working with you I
adore there's just too much to turn down
so I've been loving it great so let's
just talk about Instagram for a minute
and there have been lots of photo
sharing apps out there and Instagram has
just really I mean been the dominant
player in this space how do you what do
you attribute that to
what is what's the key to that success I
give a lot of credit Kevin in to Mike
Sisco Kevin Systrom into my krieger who
are the two founders they have I think
there are a couple things they they have
this one of the values we have at
Instagram is to do the simple thing
first and I think it's an incredibly
valuable thing to take with you through
life systems only get more complex as
they grow so you have to start simple
because if you start simple it will get
more complex if you start complex you're
in trouble so the idea of doing the
simple thing first is boiling down the
problem you're solving to its most sort
of essential pieces and making sure you
get that right before you worry about
all the other details it also you can
also use it when you're trying to build
something you know we have we have a lot
of ideas not all of them are good ideas
but you don't know at the beginning as
you're starting to think about it which
which is which necessarily and so doing
the simple thing first means sometimes
also building the simple thing first
seeing if your hunches are right seeing
if it resonates with the people to use
Instagram and if it doesn't because you
built the simple thing first you can
throw it away and you haven't invested
too much time in it if it does you can
continue to build on it so it leads to
this sort of quick iteration cycle where
you you test ideas rapidly and you
hopefully converge to the right thing is
something that's meaningful for people
quickly the thing that I think they do
insanely well is focus it's a
Kevin and Mike are very good at saying
no to things and sort of through their
through their modeling of this Instagram
is very good at saying no to things so
there are there are so many
opportunities that we say no to because
we're trying to focus we're trying to do
fewer things really well there's a the
the CEO of Under Armour has has this
there's a story that I love Under Armour
started out as a small company they're
now a competitor Nike so they're doing
shoes they're doing they do everything
right in his office there's a whiteboard
and there's a million things written all
over it but in the center surrounded by
a bunch of empty space it says remember
to sell t-shirts through everything else
they're doing
remember to serve the customer remember
why you exist and keep that the focus
all the other things that you have to do
to grow to build a successful company
you do them so that you can fulfill your
mission so that you can build a great
product for all the people in our case
all the people to use Instagram and I
think one of the things that makes
Instagram special is we keep that at the
center of everything we do and we don't
let the other things be their own
purpose the other things are in service
to building a great product so can you
talk a little bit about the relationship
between Instagram and Facebook it must
be quite interesting how how integrated
is it and how independent are you yeah
we're very independent and we get a ton
of value from Facebook and those two
things don't don't seem like they meshed
immediately but it's the best of both
worlds and I I've never seen anything
like it mark and Mark Zuckerberg and
Kevin Systrom deserve a lot of credit
for like how they have set this thing up
because it really is the best of both
worlds so we we rely heavily on Facebook
for things like infrastructure you know
they have data centers around the world
they have scalable systems that we can
just begin using if they meet our use if
they meet our needs and that means we
can go faster we leverage their sales
team so if you're an advertiser you can
use the same interfaces you're already
using the advertise on Facebook to
advertise on Instagram if we need
business development contacts around the
world Facebook has teams around the
world that we're able to use
so we get all of that value but then
from a product standpoint in terms of
what we build in terms of what how we
evolve Instagram
we're totally independent so we do
what's right for the Instagram community
Facebook does what's right for the
Facebook community and as a result we
get to be this tiny company that has you
know super powers from being a part of
Facebook but we get to move fast and
build what's right for our product which
is not always the same as what's right
for Facebook or for whatsapp or for
oculus or the other things that are a
part of overall Facebook so it works
really well it is not like sometimes you
end up doing the same thing sometimes
you end up doing different things and in
the same way that that somebody else
within Facebook wouldn't tell us
oh no we're building that you can't
build it we don't tell anyone else that
either so we we work pretty
independently but we look for ways that
we can help each other if there are
opportunities so you talked about focus
but of course you have to keep
innovating so where do ideas come from
do they come from inside do they come
from customers do they come from looking
at the competitive landscape you know
where do ideas come from and how do you
then evaluate that it's a great question
I don't know that there's a formula for
it I
my personal belief good ideas come from
everywhere then that means that means
good ideas come from from folks internal
to Instagram good ideas also come from
from folks outside of Instagram there
are a whole lot of smart people a lot
more smart people outside of Instagram
then there are inside right so good
ideas come from everywhere we try and do
a lot of research we try and actually
you know sit down and talk with people
and understand why they're using
Instagram and how we could do how we
could build a better product for them we
also were looking at data all the time
to try to see what sort of latent trends
there are and what people are showing us
that they want to do and we have a sense
of what we want Instagram to become we
think a lot about how Instagram
strengthens relationships through shared
experiences so you're closer to people
in your life to people that you know to
your friends because of Instagram you're
also probably closer to to the the
things the interest you have the
passions you have sports teams you care
about musicians you care about
because of Instagram you're seeing what
they're doing in their life through the
Instagram feed
you're watching their Instagram stories
you join them when they go live you're
closer to the people in your life
because of Instagram and so internally
we think about how we can build products
that that continue to strengthen
relationships with the people and the
things you care about so can you talk a
little bit about experimentation so
let's say an idea comes in you think
it's kind of good what happens and when
do you know if it works or if it doesn't
work and what do you do if it's not
working well you don't see the ones that
don't work for the most part maybe 1% of
you do for a period of time and then you
give an example let me just maybe that
was helpful
gosh an example I mean we tried we try
so many things like we're we're probably
running 50 experiments right now and
they are everything from bigger things
that like you know some things that are
that are successful but you'll see
launch in the coming days and weeks to
algorithm changes and smaller things
that may be totally behind the scenes
but that that change like what surfaces
to you on Instagram and how things are
ranked and how we prioritize what you
should what you see in like who you
could follow so it's it's across the
board
I think one of the things that that
really does separate Facebook and
Instagram is the speed at which we can
experiment the tooling around it
everybody can launch their own
experiment it doesn't take nobody has to
go you know ask me or ask Kevin Systrom
if they can do an experiment if it's
very user facing of course we think we
think about the impact it'll have but
most experiments are smaller you know if
you're testing changes to the new user
flow for example does changing the order
of these things or does asking these
questions in a different way help people
understand what Instagram is and become
successful users faster people can just
launch experiments like that at all
times and then data automatically gets
tabulated and without anybody doing work
you can see which experiments are make
meaningful differences in our metrics
and it happens very quickly and so lots
of small learnings like that add up and
you know a percent here percent there a
percent here a few times a week suddenly
over the course of a quarter
40% better than when you started and I
think it really is meaningful like you
you press writes about big product
launches and those things are very
important
but I think what people miss is the
daily just like getting a little bit
better every single day that Facebook
and Instagram are better than anybody
I've ever seen
that's terrific so I know that the
product is used quite differently in
different parts of the world how does
that affect your product design and
development and if the product actually
different if you go to different places
around the globe yeah it's one of the
hardest parts of building a product from
here in the US our audience is global we
have 700 million people around the world
to use Instagram and you know maybe 20
ish percent of them are in the US so 80
percent are outside the US in a
different country a lot of those people
are in very different circumstances they
you know in many cases you know we I bet
most people in this room have iPhones
the majority of people using Instagram
have Android phones we all live on good
networks there are a lot of people use
Instagram around the world on bad
networks on no networks you know you
need to think about things like
downloading things while you're on Wi-Fi
because you can't depend on a cellular
connection so there are very different
sort of physical circumstances there are
also different social norms people think
about privacy very differently than you
and I maybe if we get a follower on
Instagram we're like oh cool one more
follower there are people in the world
who when they get a follower they think
why is that person fall I don't know
that person why you know and there's a
so you have very very different contexts
around the world we try and do a lot of
research we try and actually get out and
talk to people all over the world as a
way of getting a better sense of what
their needs are and how they think about
Instagram you know we send we send
product managers researchers designers
engineers to different places in the
world because there's no substitute for
actually getting out and talking to
users so is the product actually
different in different regions or is it
the same product that you have to figure
out how to sort of walk that narrow line
between these different cultures
fundamentally it's the same product but
sort of in small ways it may act if
they emphasize different things but you
know there's not a different tab in a
different country or anything like that
is nothing nothing hugely significant
like that well one thing that's always
really interesting to me is about how
organizations build a culture and I'd
like to get your take on what the
culture is at Instagram and what's your
levers you use with your team to
reinforce that mm-hmm I think one of the
one of the great things about Instagram
like I talked about one of the reasons I
joined was the size that like our PM
team is now thirty people and that's we
all fit in one room and so a big part of
it for me is building a team that feels
like family where we all know each other
we all know each other well we have a
lot of trust in each other part of that
means had being comfortable enough to
give each other hard feedback as well to
to be able to say what you authentically
think because when you can do that it
builds trust and it brings everybody
closer you kind of have to do that when
the team is small or when the team is
large you're never going to have that so
we have that opportunity and I think the
culture again Kevin and Mike deserve all
the credit for this because it was true
well long before I got there but it's a
company that feels like a family and I
that sounds cliche but it's it's a group
great group of people and it's a group
of people that I think are really
motivated by the mission of like
bringing people closer together around
the world so in a few minutes I'm going
to open up to questions from the
audience I've got a few more questions
here but you can start thinking about
the really hard questions you can ask
Kevin so let's I want to talk about your
personal life you have a lot going on
you are an ultramarathon runner you've
got three little kids you know two and a
half year old and six month old twins
how do you balance all of that I mean
this is that sounds pretty complicated
you've got a big job and you have a lot
of other things going on outside of work
I mean balance is a very generous term
for what we do you sleep not much that's
mostly what we sacrifice haha no I mean
I my wife Elizabeth talks a lot about
having having something
like a handful of things in your life
that are non-negotiable that that you're
going to stick to no matter what because
they're important to you and to who you
are for us for both of us
fortunately running is one of those
things so it's just it did I need the my
morning run every day to sort of level
set and you know no matter how little
sleep I've gotten if I get a run in I'm
good for the day and so the morning is
spending time with kids and getting a
run in then we both go to work thank
goodness we have an incredible nanny who
would deeply trust and who's wonderful
with our kids and then get home and it's
insanity for like two or three hours
you're all welcome to come over and
witness it any time we'll take we'll
take any help we can get trying to get
three kids fed into bed and and all of
that so you know life is insane
basically from like six to nine and then
we either try and spend a little time
with each other or go back to work kind
of depending on the day so being a
long-distance runner has that training
been helpful for you at all and thinking
about what you do in an entrepreneur
environment is there any is that a
metaphor in some way that you can apply
it's interesting um I think let's see so
if you're I like I like running long
races 50k 50 miles things like that and
there's not a lot of there's no a lot of
tricks to running a 50 mile race you
kind of start running and you just keep
running and you know you go through some
ups and downs you go through some
periods where you feel good you go
through some periods where you feel bad
but you just keep running and like
that's actually the key to success I
think there is some analogy in this
which is like every company has ups and
downs every product you work on has ups
and downs every class you take
everything you do has ups and downs I
think people underestimate the value of
just like fighting through it and you
know staying determined staying the
course and coming out the other side
stronger there's you know I said one of
the things that I think Facebook and
Instagram are good at that people don't
recognize is like getting a little bit
better every
single day and that that comes in in
training for a racism stuff as well
right you put in your 10 miles at 5:00
a.m. when no one else is out on the
roads and you get a little bit better
and maybe nobody sees it but you get a
little bit better I think that's that's
very true of your work in companies it's
easy to get discouraged or you know to
sort of ride the ups and downs too much
but you stay focused on getting just a
little bit better every single day
and you may not notice it from like
Monday to Tuesday to Wednesday to
Thursday but you definitely notice it
from 2016 to 2017 to 2018 great
so let's flashback to when you were a
student imagine I mean it's not that
long ago when were you in graduate
school where longer than I did I realize
it grad school like 10 or 11 years I was
going to say 10 years it's almost 10
years ago yeah when you were sitting in
this room listening to talks right and
what do you wish you had learned then
that would have made things easier
essentially helped helped you in ways
that you wish you would have known then
this is any personal this is my own
answer to this question but people or
everything you know one actually creates
anything in a vacuum no one actually
does anything on their own everything
that you accomplish you accomplish with
teams and success is surrounding
yourself with other great people who are
smarter than you who push you who are
better than you at lots of things I
think you know academically maybe I
realized that but you don't like you
know now we've lived it for for 10 or 11
years like everything you've
accomplished you do because you're
surrounded by great people so finding
ways to surround yourself by the best
people you possibly can the smartest
people the people that push you to be
better is it's probably the best thing
you can do it's also like as I as I grew
within Twitter every job that I had was
the biggest job that I've ever had I was
managing more people than I'd ever
managed I had more responsibilities than
I'd ever had before and like it was
happening really fast and it was
intimidating
it's always like that question of well I
figured out how to do this job but now
I've got this responsibility like oh oh
what am I not sure I can do this you go
talk to other people and you realize
you're doing this job but there's
somebody up here who's like doing this
and if they can do this I'll figure this
one out so people also give me
personally people give me a lot of
perspective and they I don't know I feel
like the more the more I've been exposed
to different ways of thinking different
approaches to the world realizing I
don't know I don't think I would have
been able to do the things that I have
if I hadn't like focused so much on
learning from other people and being
around people who are better than me in
every possible way cool who has the
first question
great over here um so I'll ask a
question that I asked Facebook insecure
and I didn't get a very good answer
this morning okay gird your loins
serious you know what frameworks or
guides or codes of conduct you employ
within Facebook Instagram around how you
employ consumer behaviors psychology to
nudge users in one way or another in a
way that you feel it's appropriate it
conforms your future values and is
ultimately ethical something so I'll
speak about Instagram because that's the
only place I've worked um you know it
it's a good question
I'm not sure that it comes up and that's
sort of an abstract way of thinking
about things and we tend to approach
problems much more pragmatically so I'm
just trying to best answer your question
here um well let me ask you so let me
let me see if I can sort of phrase it in
a way that might be here
do you have an ethical code of that that
ends up influencing the way the product
gets shaped is that yes I mean
we try and go back to our mission as
much as possible because I think when
you if you have a mission that you
believe in and you try and use that
mission to guide decisions then you're
going to make decisions in a consistent
way and you're going to make them with
an eye to the future that you're trying
to create so our mission is to
strengthen relationships through shared
experiences so we think if we were
making the decision you know feed
ranking for example is is a place where
you can think about these kinds of
problems if you're going to you follow a
bunch of people on Instagram you follow
brands that you care about you follow
sports teams you follow musician
celebrities and you follow some of your
closest friends it's a hard problem
figuring out like what you optimize for
when you're trying to when you're trying
to rank the feed and if our mission is
to strengthen relationships we think a
lot about you know how do we bring you
closer to the people that you care most
about and one of the things that that we
have thought a lot about is is that
leads you to making sure that you you
see what your friends are up to and I
I'm trying to give a good answer to your
question I'm not going to say it like
doesn't I guess I haven't felt the
tension at Instagram that maybe you're
referencing Instagram we're trying to
create a product that feels that where
you feel safe where you feel comfortable
where you know you don't face harassment
and abuse a product that makes you happy
because it shows you great experiences
that your friends are having or the
people or products that you care about
brands that you care about athletes that
you care about experiences that they're
having so it's a really good question
I'm not sure my answer is very
satisfactory but I'll just say like we
haven't felt that tension I guess in in
everyday life and when it comes to
running experiments we only run
experiments that we think we would ship
so you know we don't we don't tend to do
at Instagram sort of abstract learning
experiments
of maybe of the kind you're referencing
we try and we try and run experiments
around things that we actually think
make Instagram fundamentally better for
the people that use it right yes thank
you what do you think
Instagram yeah can I want to repeat the
question so the person is talk about the
process of decision-making around
introducing Instagram stories will you
give me a license to talk for like four
or five minutes about this because I
think the backstory is really
interesting so the the tension in the
question is you've got snapchat which
has the stories product and and here's
where we were about a year ago Instagram
was a product for your highlights
it started out if you go back to the
very beginning of Instagram as a place
where you would share anything you share
all the moments of your life but as the
community grew more and more people join
Instagram more and more people follow
you you start to feel like well the last
thing I posted got 30 likes since I'm
going to get 30 likes I don't know maybe
I just won't post in the the quality bar
that was required to post on Instagram
kept going up people self imposed
quality bar kept going up and it meant
that Instagram became a place not for
all of your moments but for your
highlights for the absolute best things
that happened in your life and that
means it was a great product to consume
because what you were seeing was
literally some of the greatest things
that were going on in your friends lives
but how many highlights do you have in a
week two three it doesn't happen all the
time so a product that's just for your
highlights like that it wasn't what we
set out to become so we wanted to get
back to the world where Instagram is a
place where you felt comfortable sharing
all of your moments and when you think
about so if that's your goal you think
about well why aren't people doing that
today well you're probably not going to
share if you're going to share all of
your moment you're going to share more
of your like sort of raw daily like
here's just here's what I'm doing this
isn't anything super special just like
here's what I'm doing your friends care
about that right because they care about
you if you're going to share that you're
probably not going to share that ten
times a day to a fee
which is the way Instagram always
historically worked if there are social
norms around a feed right so rather than
being feed oriented if you're going to
build a product that people share to
consistently multiple times throughout
the day it needs to be more person
oriented than feed oriented another
reason that people don't share all the
time is that the quality bar like is
this going to be good enough I'm this
thing just happened to me I kind of want
to share it but like last time I got a
hundred likes am I going to get a
hundred likes on this I don't think I
know I'm just not going to share that so
people self-censor because they because
of because the feedback is public they
know they don't want to post something
that gets 50 likes when their last one
got 100 so if you want some people just
feel comfortable sharing all the time
you don't want public feedback you want
private feedback and then the other
thing is people's Instagram profiles are
sacred to them it's a representation of
who they are you can go to someone's
Instagram profile and get a sense of
like who they are how they represent
themselves what their life is like and
so if you want them to share ten times a
day rather than it being permanently
posted to your profile forever
you probably want ephemerality because
again it frees you up to feel
comfortable posting more so you end up
in this world where you want a person
oriented format you want private
feedback and you want a firmer ality and
so this was sort of the logically we
went through and as we we sort of we got
at this place we're like oh you put
those three things together like that's
a snapchat story oh like that's why
that's why that the snapchat story
format is so powerful it has those
things and they work together to make
you feel comfortable sharing all these
moments in your life and when we realize
that we're like that this is we feel
like this is a this is a valuable thing
to exist on Instagram we don't need to
feel like there's no reason to call it a
different name we don't need to give it
a different label is a story and because
it's stories we felt like it was going
to be a format that people adopted in
the same way that a mobile feed didn't
used to be a thing and a hashtag didn't
used to be a thing and now you see them
everywhere across lots of products
snapchat was the
first to create the story format and
more power to them they did a fantastic
job but we felt like it was a format
that was going to be powerful in a lot
of different products and so we adopted
it and it's been the fastest growing
product I think I've ever seen we went
from 0 to 200 million people using it
every single day in about 8 months
Wow great is any sense yes this is back
in your pot coming from a hobbit
undergraduate concentration and fitting
and coming out from Stanford to continue
further research in physics and then
cause getting the tank positive the
energy that's part of Silicon Valley
deciding to throw all that away we'll
put that on hold up and jump into the
tech business what advice you have to
kind of be undergrads neighbor and young
entrepreneurs who are very excited about
the energy but also really want to focus
on their studies and become experts in a
given field so the question is about the
tension between being a student and
really excelling at that versus looking
at opportunities outside an industry and
when deicide jumps ship to go and pursue
that opportunity yeah I think just if
you keep if you keep sort of following
your nose and doing the things that are
exciting to you good things are going to
happen so you know if you're if you're
really into into CS like go deep on CS
and that that will only yield good
things if you're really in Toronto
corner supply you are at the best place
in the world to understand
entrepreneurship people people start
companies at the same time as they're
going to school you can you can learn so
much from this environment I talked a
lot about surrounding yourself with good
people I mean look at this place you're
surrounded by some of the best people in
the world learn from them take every
advantage of it there's something really
magical about being at an institution
like Stanford I miss it in a lot of ways
I wish I could come back maybe someday
you know penny oh thank you so I think I
think there's you can learn so much
about anything you want to learn about
while you're at Stanford
whether it's entrepreneurship or going
deep in CS or like studying Russian lit
because like you're never going to get
to study Russian lit ever again so why
not I don't know I think
I think you can sort of do all the
things while you're here and you should
take advantage of it and do that but I
have to be much exactly the same
educational backgrounds you and I am so
impressed that I did all the time it
seemed or somehow not good even though
this student is not an effective or some
adults at heart even though the students
are all in particular brilliance and
poke about teamwork created ways in
succeeded at all I don't really have any
job on how we could drink this like data
teamwork models for companies in my
house into the classroom that we could
actually earn a lot more please proof
reject yeah so the question is how do
you really prepare students to be great
team players and companies and how do
you bring this or the culture of
teamwork in companies in a classroom
settings you know I wonder if part of it
is motivation I think the best companies
have a mission that inspires people and
everybody comes in to work hard and
fight through the the hard parts of a
start-up and the great parts of the
startup because they believe in the
mission that's certainly been true of
the best companies I've ever worked at
and there's a lot of research that shows
that people are motivated by other
things if they're motivated by money if
they're motivated by a grade like that's
you don't get the same quality of work
out of anybody so I wonder if part of it
is figuring out why you're doing what
you're doing and making the motivation
something much bigger than getting a
great grade in a class but making it
about learning for your future making it
about you know whatever whatever it
happens to be there's something bigger
than just the immediate classroom
setting I wouldn't put it only on the
teacher the question was is it on the
teacher and I think it I think maybe
great teachers can can start to do that
but if that's not happening or if it
doesn't resonate with everyone then
great students can do it as well tap
into your fictional internal motivation
yeah great super
so what advice
in terms of organizing comes yeah I'm
talking about you know what have you
mentioned that everybody could
experiment and it's not showing through
any kind of Iraqi leadership cream some
other including my serious masters I
guess the question is how might you
organize a startup to inspire this type
of innovation yeah I don't know that
there is a single answer to that I think
it naturally changes as you grow you
know the way you organize a five-person
startup is very different than the way
you organize and operate a 50-person is
very different than the way we organize
and offer at Instagram today at 4 or 500
you know it kind of every time you
double things change and by the time
you've 10x like things definitely are
different so I think it's natural when
you're really small to be a lot more
founder lead where things do go through
the founder you don't have the bandwidth
if you're six people to have people
running different experiments and other
things you you want to have a very very
crystal clear goal and and operate
entirely around that like trying to find
product market fit I think it becomes
different once you've found product
market fit and you're growing and trying
to scale and it starts to become more
and more important to for the mission
not to just be in the founders head but
for the mission to be something that
everybody can repeat for the most
important like you should be able to go
around to your company as it scales and
ask anybody what are the three most
important things we're working on and if
people give different answers then
you've got work to do everybody should
be able to give the same answer
everybody should be able to talk about
the mission and how those things that
you're doing the three most important
things relate back to the mission and so
the more you can the more you can get
everybody focused on the same things and
understanding the mission the more you
can distribute decision-making down into
teams and hopefully move faster in
parallel with everyone going the same
direction if you don't want to move
faster with everyone going different
directions at all times you want to you
want to move faster that everyone going
in parallel and that's that's what the
missions for right another question back
there one question for competition so
sodium dollies litter
with incumbents who define a product
category as your currently does and
small scrappy companies come up with
disruptive innovation and not a lot that
for this competition keeps you up at
night you possibly looking about how you
dealt with snap how to use a company
deal with that kind of competitive so
how do you think about your competitors
um you definitely think about your
competitors but you don't let it drive
why you do what you do you know I think
you're silly if you say oh I'm not going
to think about it at all I'm just not
even going to know because your
competitors if they're if they're doing
well it's because they've tapped into
something and I think the important
thing is to understand what that
something is understand how or if it
relates to what you're trying to do and
if there's something that you can learn
from it but it's really important to
stay focused on what you are trying to
accomplish in the world that the mission
of your own company and not get too
distracted but if you're not learning
from what's working if you're not
learning from how people are changing
and evolving and like finding different
use cases for you know for things like
sharing experiences then you're silly so
so it's sort of if it's knowing what's
going on but then understanding how or
if it applies to the goal that you're
trying to solve
I was wondering um haven't fake news
impact Instagram and how is it being
addressed and how is that problem
similar or different for what Facebook
cases so you want review the question
yeah yeah so how do you deal with fake
news and do you have the same sort of
issues at Facebook have yeah it's a very
it's a very different problem on
Instagram and a lot of that is because
of the structure of the product so on
Instagram we don't have links the best
you can do is you get one link in your
bio but you don't get to attach a link
to the post that you make you also can't
reshare things on Instagram so if you
post on Instagram and I see it and I
love it there's no way for me to take
your post and share it to my friends
it reduces virality that's intentional
because we want Instagram to be a place
where you feel comfortable sharing your
experiences and it's less about you
being able to take someone else's
experience that they share to you and
like share it all you're like it's more
about experiences and less about like
less about sharing a link and both of
those things are key to the way that
news real or fake
spreads on platforms like Facebook and
Twitter so it's less of a thing that
isn't to say that we don't think about
it but it's it's a much less - much
smaller issue on Instagram today in part
because of the were in large part
because the way the service works so let
me ask you about this you talked a lot
about using Instagram to connect people
together and to build communities today
happens also to be the day that Facebook
released their quarterly results which
is all about making returns and you know
return on investment how do you think
about monetization as you're developing
the product yeah mark has a great line
about this which is you know we the
Facebook and Instagram as well exists to
fulfill our mission for Facebook it's
about making the world more open and
connected for Instagram it's about
strengthening relationships or shared
experiences you make money you build a
business so that you can keep the
company going and and do a better job of
fulfilling your mission over time like
you will not be able to fulfill your
mission if you don't also have a strong
and growing company so revenue isn't the
purpose of what we do but it does power
what we do and we certainly couldn't do
it without having a business also the
the model that we the way we make
revenue is through advertising
advertising appears in the Instagram
feed it appears in between Instagram
stories so it appears with the content
it's part of the consumer experience and
so we hold it to the same bar that we
hold every bit of the Instagram
experience - it's no different so the
ads products for us are products in the
exact same way that any other product
build an Instagram is we don't live to
build ads products but they're a
critical part of what we do and they're
you know we wouldn't be Instagram
without it cool another question
these students back there stand up
really tall is a Latino background you
know a lot of extreme significant mass
that there's nutrients which to the
product side out the word and after that
which you can quickly able to excel
actually in your role and pretty quickly
get to the top can you share a little
bit what were the most important things
that help you with that switch for us
and while you were exciting in your
position so the question is about you
you really trained as an engineer as a
scientist as a physicist and then you
ended up doing really really different
things what allowed you to excel when
you change into this new world
yeah can I actually go back to the last
question for just a second I left out
something important and then I'll get to
this question which is you talk about
strengthening relationships to shared
experiences and the way that the
monetization weaves in products that we
all have brands that we love and we all
have products that we love and it's
actually a big part of our lives and so
I think the thing that I left out is
realizing that Instagram wouldn't
actually be complete if we didn't give
businesses an opportunity to reach out
to the people that they they care about
them
the people that use their products and
love their products and so you know for
us revenue advertising at its best is
showing you it's introducing you to to
brands and products that you love that
you buy that make your life better and
that's sort of the ideal that we strive
for and that's also the way that
incentives get aligned like we want we
want advertising content to be great
content advertisers want to create great
content because that's what leads to
consumers ultimately buying their
products and because we want to
Instagram to be full to be a great
experience itself like all these things
weave together and if we do it right the
incentives are totally aligned and we
can make ads that are also a great
product I just I think it's an important
like when you think about finding a
business model for the startup
you work in whatever you're working on
you want to find ways to align the
incentives of your varying customers
because if they're mismatched you're
going to run into problems down the road
and advertising is a great business
model because it the incentives between
the people who use Instagram and the
advertisers who want to reach those
users are actually aligned you just want
to see great content and advertisers
want to reach the people that did love
them that buy their products cool so
great yeah back to ya so let's see the
switch us first about switching from
engineering into product it wasn't so
purposeful like it was kind of
accidental it was a thing that and this
will be the metaphor for the answer to
your entire question actually the fun
thing about being at a company that's
growing quickly is you kind of don't
know all the things you're going to need
until you run into them and then you
they're always way more things to do
than there are people to do them in a
growing company and that means that it
leaves a lot of opportunities for people
who who want to dig a little bit deeper
who wanted to want to try something new
who want to like look for another
opportunity to to do that so for me like
somebody needs to go out and talk to the
businesses that we were building for is
we're starting to think about building
analytics products at Twitter and I
volunteered it seemed interesting and
anyways the rest of my team were better
engineers than I was so I felt like I
was maximizing productivity by doing it
too and then as we grew and as that
product turned into our advertising
business and that team grew and grew I
didn't always you know it wasn't a
linear path at various points there were
managers that were brought in above me
and sometimes that's disappointing but
you also look to see like what can you
learn from each of the people that you
work with what do they do better than
than you do and like how can you how can
you understand that how can you make
yourself better so that when the time
comes and you get another opportunity
you're ready to take it and so you know
I was lucky that the business kept
growing which meant there were more
opportunity
sort of every every few months there
were new opportunities and like I said I
had a few people that took bets on me
and I worked really hard to to make sure
that those that I made those bets good
ones
great yeah hi now one of the things that
you talked about your discussion with
like Instagram strength is ability to
make broken but at the same time like
how you say no to ideas no way that
doesn't discourage boys from completely
get out ideas and like my second
question is like kind of related what we
said earlier about talent everywhere
that company should know what the three
most important things are the commission
of a company but I do know your company
how do you make sure that you're
communicating with valued compliments so
there are two questions one has to do
with if you've got a culture of being
really really focused how do you not
discourage people when you say no to
their ideas and then we'll get to the
next question yeah look it's I mean we
all are users of the product too so
people come forward with great ideas
that we just can't quite get to yet and
we're right there with them they're like
I would love that I wish that existed in
Instagram you're totally right Instagram
would be better for that we just have to
do these three things first because they
are more impactful they're more they're
going to be better for the community if
we do it's very rare that someone comes
up with an idea that's just like oh no I
don't think that's right it's usually
that's a great idea
we need to do these things really well
first and so that if you do those if you
do them quickly often you can get to the
other ideas over time so the second
question had to do with how do you
actually communicate the value so that
everybody in the organization is really
marching in step you say it over and
over and over and over and over again
it's you know none of us remember things
the first time we hear them so I think
it's important to get to find different
ways to remind people of you know what
our mission is Instagram why are we here
why do we do what we do why is that so
important to the world and also to like
reference priorities as often as you can
if you listen to mark and Cheryl for
example when they talk about Facebook
you know if you go listen to the
earnings call today they'll get asked
questions and they do a fantastic job of
saying well our mission
in is to make the world more open and
connected and so answer the question and
it's just like you do things like that
that remind people it's not just giving
an answer to the question it's reminding
what reminding you why you're here and
then that also usually helps you answer
the question if you would think back to
what is the mission the mission often
will help guide you towards the way you
would answer the question so I want to
ask the last question okay obviously you
have had a really incredible career run
in this ten years since you've left
school what clothing advice at this
stage in your life would you give to the
folks who are sitting in the room oh man
bring this one on me at the end I think
I would go back honestly I would go back
to what I said about people and this is
my own personal answer it doesn't need
to be your answer
but my favorite thing is being
surrounded by people that are smarter
than me that pushed me to be better that
you know teach me show me areas where I
could be better to compliment whose
strengths compliment my weaknesses and I
feel like the more I'm in rooms like
that the happier I am the better things
that we build the like the bigger stuff
that I get to be a part of it's like I
think it's you know I I've learned that
it it both like makes me the happiest
and and leads to the to the biggest
successes I think so surround yourself
with amazing people people that are
better than you people that are smarter
than you people that push you to be
better fabulous thank you so much please
join me
you